hey youtubers is Charlie so this week
was the agents of shield finale and I'd
say about half the questions we had were
answered you know about half were teased
for season two like they're gonna
continue those plots into season two and
then in like the last 15 minutes a whole
bunch of new questions came up so this
is what I'm gonna do because we got a
confirmed season two I'm gonna start
with my top 5 moments then do my review
and then do theory crafting for season 2
if you're finding me for the first time
every week I do Marvel videos but
because agents of shield is going on
hiatus now every Tuesday is just gonna
be Marvel movie and Star Wars video days
so be sure to subscribe to get
everything and feel free to leave me
suggestions for bonus videos to do so
careful for spoilers from the episode if
you haven't seen it yet but here are my
top 5 moments number five Fitz
sacrifices himself for Simmons I feel
like the sacrifice means so much more
whenever it's not a superhero like when
Thor jumps into a hurricane
you're 99% sure he's gonna escape
without a scratch on him but drowning at
the bottom of the ocean and confessing
your love for someone is just so much
more meaningful they kept talking about
the life on the bottom of the ocean and
I half expected some Atlanteans to swim
up and save them but I think that was
just an easter-egg Coulson did take more
chances with his life but since he's
already been proven unkillable Fitz made
the biggest sacrifice in the episode and
as a result he's paying the biggest
price it sounds like based on what they
said in the episode that whenever his
character does come back he'll be
fundamentally changed like he will not
be the Fitz of season 1 it'll be like
someone totally different number 4 Nick
Fury saves the day he got an
introduction in the episode befitting
his level of badassery if you're
confused about the timeline between the
end of Winter Soldier now it's basically
moving in real-time so it's only been a
couple of months so as of this episode
Fury has left shield and he's just
hunting for Hydra agents on his own when
he entered the episode it kind of felt
like he was walking on to a holodeck
like he knew nothing was gonna hurt him
which seems totally appropriate for the
character my favorite Nick Fury line in
the episode was that one man part one
man can be part of something greater
part of something greater when he left
at the end and said I'm everywhere it
was just the writers leaving room for
him to cameo on the show again next
season Marvel does this really awesome
thing where they never throw characters
away which actually kind of ties into my
next moment
number three Coulson takes down Garrett
more like liquefies him with the
tesseract gun this was just like the end
of that moment at the Avengers when the
Hulk thrashed Loki around Garrett has
this moment of evil triumph like he
thinks he's escaped and bam you get this
Joss Whedon head jerk to Coulson
I just love how nonchalant he is about
the whole moment it just completely
subverts our expectations and that's why
it's so good it was moments like that
early on in the Marvel movie universe
that made Coulson such a fan favorite
just him casually reacting to extreme
situations Oh Asgardian robot killing
everything in the desert hmm isn't that
interesting the only bad part is is that
moments like that really spoil you and
since we only get to see him every once
in a while I'm a little bummed now that
it's gonna be almost all year before we
get to see it again like guardians of
the galaxy but to be fair Asians of
shield will premiere before that so
maybe we'll get like a season 2 episode
1 you know Coulson funny moment also
quick sidenote - now we know that the
tesseract Gunn is more powerful than to
destroy our gun number 2 Skye is an
important part of the evolution we
didn't get an official answer one way or
the other about what she was but Raina
and Garrett mentioned the words
evolution and becoming something greater
in almost every scene they were in so
I'm gonna go ahead and save some of the
theories for my season 2 part of the
video but I love the way the show is
doing this crazy cosmic comic-book
rhetoric in ways that allow them to not
have to show it to us right away I kind
of did expect carrot to morph into
something crazy whenever deathlok's
smashed him though earlier whenever he
said this is the beginning of the end he
was talking about throwing things into
the next stage of evolution that really
did make me think Terrigen mists and
Inhumans because something similar
happened during Marvel infinity during
that comic book last year and Marvel has
really made it clear that they're trying
to develop an Inhumans movie and all
that business with Skye's father at the
end of the episode just makes me feel
like there are multiple types of aliens
on the show it's not just one or the
other it's like you know a whole bunch
of stuff the problem in trying to figure
out who is what depends all on whether
or not
Inhumans would be able to take a
transfusion from accrete you know a la
tahiti blue alien who I definitely think
is a Kree regardless of all that I
definitely think that Raina is an
inhuman the term monster just fits so
well since sometimes Inhumans turn into
physical
monstrous looking things whenever they
inhale the mists so in a way shield is
setting up all these big galactic things
on television the show in the movies
don't cross over all the time and when
they do it's really subtle but the
events on the show will influence what
happens in the movies in vice-versa
naturally you just expected more from
the movies flowing down rather than the
show flowing up and my number one moment
Coulson is tasked with rebuilding shield
I suspected this might end up being the
case but I never predicted that Coulson
would become director of shield that
black box is probably gonna be the
MacGuffin for season two the thing that
gives them their missions we could talk
about that in a second but we found out
they have another new secret base with
another Patton Oswalt I got so happy I'm
gonna go ahead and say life model decoy
wouldn't it be funny though if there was
a Patton Oswalt life model decoy at
every single one of Nick Fury's secret
bases like 50 or 60 of them
it'd just be a whole army of Patton
Oswalt's playing video games in the dark
by themselves or maybe in like a massive
Call of Duty land party I have to say
though my favorite quote from the
episode was Garrett saying I am the key
to the future of the universe it was
just so Machiavellian and so perfect but
now it's your turn let me know what your
favorite moment was from the episode or
moments it's really hard to pick I felt
a lot of Whedon verse mojo in this
episode and that's why it was so amazing
overall the episode was a solid a
definitely a high point for the season
Bill Paxton has been a breath of fresh
air for the show and I'm only sorry that
he didn't get to come on sooner but I
think that was mostly because that
whenever they started the show only had
a six episode commitment so they didn't
even know if they were gonna get renewed
they even shot the first three episodes
before episode 1 ever aired so they
didn't even get feedback from the fandom
until they were midway through the first
half of the season but now that the
heavy lifting task of developing all the
core characters is over I think that
they can really start to have a lot more
fun and get really really meta
I really love what they did with Ward's
character specifically Brett Dalton is
still kind of growing on me in his fight
with may is probably the perfect
metaphor for how most people reacted to
him at least until we learned he was
Hydra it was like he was trolling us the
whole time with that vanilla quarterback
routine and Coulson was already an
amazing character whenever the show
started but now that we've got to live
with him for so much longer he's become
so much more complex
before agents of shield he was
essentially the setup man for Tony Stark
jokes which isn't a bad job but Nick
Fury named him as a core Avenger in the
episode so Marvel and Disney just made
Coulson every bit as important as
Captain America and Iron Man and the
rest of the a-list Avengers I don't
think that means we're gonna get a
Coulson movie anytime soon but I'm
totally fine with that I'm totally happy
with him just being on TV a lot of the
credit this season though goes to Jed
Whedon and Marissa Tanner on they really
did most of the work this season a lot
of people don't realize that even though
Joss Whedon was involved in getting the
show off the ground they were the ones
that ran the show while he was away
doing Avengers 2 so if you really like
the show or it grew on you a lot they're
the ones to thank also whenever they
announced shield was getting a season
two they both did this really funny
dance on Instagram to celebrate so high
fives to them they did an awesome job so
onto Theory crafting so everybody starts
canning dialogue for Easter eggs and
freeze frames for like little things in
the background but let's start off with
the season to plot that little black box
that fury gave to Coulson will be where
most of their ideas for missions come
from they used it to find that new base
that they went to so they're just gonna
keep finding interesting things in that
database to investigate
just because Patton Oswalt was there
whenever they arrived doesn't mean he's
gonna be in every episode but he's
definitely gonna cameo again they're
probably gonna spend most of their time
on that plane traveling to different
places as for the rest of the team I'm
expecting Triplett to replace Ward as
the muscle man for at least a little bit
but Brett Dalton isn't off the show he's
still gonna be a main cast member
Coulson said that they were gonna use
him to get Hydra Intel so either they're
gonna permanently house him inside that
special room on the plane or they're
gonna keep him locked up at the base but
my money is on them keeping him close by
just so me knock and slap him around
once a week
Fitz is the real big question mark it
sounds like based on what they were
saying that he is lost brain function
it's possible that part of his arc next
season will be learning how to be a team
member when he's not super smart anymore
like learning how to contribute and be
special in a whole new way he's not off
the show either so he's definitely still
on that team Garrett is definitely a
puddle of goo but I just love how funny
it is that they spent all the time and
energy and money turning him into this
cyborg just so that Coulson could kill
him and that really
awesome way the honor of being the
season 2 villain will probably fall to
sky's mystery father the inhuman he's
definitely not a Kree
moving on to Skye's heritage like I said
Raina who I suspect is an inhuman that
just hasn't taken in the mists has a
pre-existing relationship with that
mystery dad ergo my best theory right
now is that she's an inhuman but she's
not a princess or anything
blackbolt is still the king of the
Inhumans and that guy did not look like
Black Bolt he seemed pretty evil and in
case you couldn't see he was covered in
blood I totally expect this Skye
Inhumans thing to be like the Coulson
Tahiti mystery during season 1 so it's
probably gonna take almost all of season
two for them to explain what's going on
but now it's your turn let me know what
are your biggest theories for season 2
and do you agree that sky isn't inhuman
based on the evidence based on what
we've seen next week like I said because
shield is on hiatus I'm gonna be doing a
bonus Marvel movie video and a bonus
Star Wars video so be sure to subscribe
to get everything and leave me
suggestions for what you want to talk
about also big news
tomorrow is the arrow finale and the
very first flash trailer so if you check
the description I posted a link to my
master video schedule so you can find
out whenever I'm posting new videos
there's been a lot of awesome stuff
happening this week but it's all in that
list so right now click here to learn
all about the agent Carter TV show as
well as all the Netflix shows I just did
a breakdown and click here to learn all
about Ben Affleck's new Batsuit and the
new Batmobile thanks for watching I'll
see you guys tomorrow high fives
you